it's a special edition of the PFT p.m.
podcast from the barn on the Friday
afternoon he's coming to you from
somewhere in Texas he is the chief
operating officer executive vice
president and director of player
personnel for the Dallas Cowboys
Stephen Jones Stephen welcome back how
are you pal hey Mike it's great being on
I'm sitting right here in Highland Park
in my house and as I was telling you
earlier we kind of embracing these
virtual meetings interviews etc and
fired up about our football team we had
a rookie orientation this morning and
I'm moving forward I got to know how was
it decided who got to be on the boat
during the draft cuz I don't think I saw
you on the boat well I think at the end
of the day jury was on the boat and my
sister that was having a vacation a
spring break with her boys when it hit
when shelter-in-place started so she
stayed right there and because my kids
are pretty active and I've been around
him a lot I think we decided it probably
wouldn't enjoy my mother and jerry's
best interest for for me to enter their
safe haven so the big talk in the NFL
right now stephen is the schedule came
out yesterday everybody's reacting to it
when do you see the schedule of the
Cowboys games for the first time do you
see the rest of us do or do you get it
ahead of time we get it about 24 hours
ahead of time and we were able to get
that schedule and look through it and
dissect it and obviously look at all the
different matchups that we have and you
know Jerry had it Mike had it but
obviously in the best interest of the
NFL and our fans that we know break the
news to our fans and the media you know
on a coordinated basis and I think the
clubs were able to break it at 7:30 and
of course we had our our show at 8:00 so
everything went off great did you just
have your schedule you get the whole
thing 24 hours in advance no we just
have our own schedule do you ever see
drafts of it there's been talk in the
past that sometimes there are versions
that get circulated there's input from
teams does that ever happen we don't
ever get to see the drafts I do
understand that there's a lot of
different versions and a lot of
different moving parts to it and they
have to coordinate with you know some
teams on conflicts with stadiums and
things of that nature but you know
overall you know Howard Katz and Michael
North just doing an amazing job of doing
something that is very daunting and in
terms of the schedule and it obviously
has you know a lot of things that they
try to avoid and things that they're
trying to do to make our network
partners happy so you know at the end of
the day I don't see how they do it but
they pull it off and you know you're
never going to make everybody happy it
is what it is but at the end of the day
all 32 players have the same all 32
teams have the same salary cap and
don'twell and they all have great
coaching staffs great scouting staff so
you never know who are gonna be the
great teams here and in your app and you
know fans will go straight to one thing
when they first get a look at their
favorite team schedule what do you look
for first when you get the Cowboys
schedule I think the biggest thing I
look for is just are we on the road more
than you know two times that's always
tough if you got to go on a three-game
road trip kind of what what's before
you're thirsty games what's after your
Thursday games what's before your bye
week what's after your bye week and then
of course you look at your national
games your night games you know are
those on the road are they at home you
know those are some of the things and
then you know obviously you look at your
division that's huge in terms of when
you play it what time of year those type
of things so that's just a quick rundown
of some of the things that I like to
look at when I grab the schedule you've
got Washington coming to town for
Thanksgiving this year Stephen do you
prefer having a division rival for that
game or do you like getting somebody
from out of the division or maybe even
out of the conference we prefer a
division game I think it's great for our
fans obviously they love the rivalries
with the Redskins the Eagles the Giants
and I think to do it on Thanksgiving
special you know a lot of fans don't get
to come to the game they have to watch
it from their TV and so it's a great
Thanksgiving tradition cowboy fans
gathering around the TV to watch the
games and you know obviously at the end
of the day I think our rivalry games our
biggest games and that's our division
game so you know
be able to play those on Thanksgiving I
think our fans really enjoy and I
actually think our divisional fans enjoy
watching their team play on Thanksgiving
earlier this morning on pft live on
NBCSN we were talking about the Patriots
and how they are entering this new era
in their existence Tom Brady is gone
will they continue to be a major
national draw a team that generates huge
ratings a team that generates huge
interest and it got us to talking about
the Cowboys because this is a franchise
that and you know as well as I do there
hasn't been a Super Bowl appearance
since 1995 early 96 but yet the Cowboys
continue to be up and down and high and
low and whatever the team does on the
field the Cowboys are the number one
draw the Cowboys are the team that every
network wants in primetime
the Cowboys are the team that generates
the highest ratings whenever they're in
a standalone game why do you think that
is how has that managed to still be the
case after 25 years without a Super Bowl
appearance well you know my hats off to
the you know original owners the
Murchison's the bright I my hat's off to
text Ram and Tom Landry my hat's off to
Roger Staubach and Bob Lilley you know I
just think they did such a great job
early on with those long extended
periods of playoff appearances Super
Bowl wins
Super Bowl appearances obviously great
personalities Captain America you know
who went to the Naval Academy Roger
Staubach I think his bus is still the
most visited bust in the NFL Hall of
Fame and in terms of where you know what
people have interest in so you know
certainly they set the foundation and
then of course you know my father Jerry
is nothing short of Barnum and Bailey in
terms of you know not wanting to drop
the ball and lead the team in a better
place and he certainly you know has
really led our organization in terms of
a you know really not wanting to drop
the ball there and you know whether it's
a the coaches whether it's the coaching
staff whether it's the players you know
hiring a dion sanders bringing him in to
play for the Cowboys I just think you
know I think we do make it interesting
at the same time I will say this it is
the number one priority I'm not so sure
he wouldn't trade his Hall of Fame bust
to win a Super Bowl right now we were so
fortunate when we got in the league to
win three Super Bowls in five years and
then of course as you mentioned we've
been on a terrible drought and I you
know in spite of the fact that we fire
at him year in and year out and we do
think we put some really good football
teams together and you know no one
thinks more Jason Garrett than we do but
really felt like that's what it was a
perfect time to make a change that Mike
McCarthy being out there his record
speaks for itself he's one of Super Bowl
he's been to three other divisional
championship games to get to a Super
Bowl he's a winner I think he could be a
huge difference in a difference maker
for us this year especially with this
young football team that we have led by
dak Prescott you know I think we're
gonna have a really interesting offense
and of course Mike's got a great
offensive mind to go with Kellen Moore
you know we've just got a good young
football team and followed it up with
what we believe is a solid draft we
won't know for three or four years how
good those players really are but we
just feel like we've got the opportunity
to change change that narrative now and
obviously our goal yearning your outs to
get to a Super Bowl and win one and
certainly that hasn't changed and I can
tell you it's Jerry Jones it's number
one priority one thing that the
organization I think has received more
and more in recent years is praise for
finding extremely talented players and
putting together a very talented team
and look the team was wasn't always as
talented as it has been the past several
years what do you attribute that to it's
almost like you guys have cracked the
code you've figured out how to go about
building a team you know build from the
inside out all those draft picks on
offensive linemen why do you think in
recent years there's been this sense
that you guys have done a pretty damn
good job of finding highly talented
players primarily in the draft well you
know at the end of the day experience is
huge and we've been lucky enough to be
in grafter rooms for Jimmie Johnson
Barry Switzer Bill Parcells Jason
Garrett now Mike McCarthy and you learn
a lot along the way you learn a lot
different personnel people and
you know one of the things that we
figured on in free agency especially as
it came in right as we were ending our
our Superbowl run is it's very difficult
to win building a team through free
agency it's just a hard way to do it and
and we figured out you know over the
last 10 years that we need to draft well
and grow and have our players be
homegrown and the majority of our roster
is homegrown we pay our own players very
rarely do you see us you know sign in a
player in free agency to to a huge
contract a lot Deion Sanders that type
of situation so we feel really good we
feel like we've really gotten better
each year in terms of how we put up our
board I think Wilma clays been
outstanding his leadership and the draft
room I think he figured out and we
figured out together
Jerry myself and will that you need to
coordinate and have good chemistry with
your coaching staff when you're picking
players so he does a great job of really
having them be involved in the draft
feel like they're picking the players
too it resonates the players would pick
resonate with them and they want to play
them and you know that's a huge reason I
think that we've been able to build good
football teams and certainly when you
put together hopefully a draft like we
think we put together you know that ease
is the burden in free agency and you're
able to keep your homegrown products and
and keep your players but you know most
it's no secret I think most general
managers will tell you at the end of the
day you like blood you draft you got to
do it well and we've been fortunate I
think do it pretty well the last ten
years well you were fortunate this year
see deal and the Oklahoma receiver
slipped past 16 how surprised were you
to see him still there when it was time
for you to make your first pick well so
surprised that we did no telling how
many my drafts also their own strategy
sessions where we throw up two players
three players four players
he was never in that mix when we were
having those conversation because we
really felt like he's the best receiver
on our board he had tied for the fourth
highest rated grade on our board he was
the sixth player on her board but you
know we just really felt like we met
he'd never get out of the top ten and
when he got there obviously our needs
were corner and pass rusher just
the sitting area is a very interesting
player for us but CD was just he had to
bigger grading too good a player not to
take we've lost Randall Cobb we had to
really proven receivers on the roster we
needed knew we needed to address it it
was deep receiver group was deep in this
draft we thought we might could wait to
the second third round you know to
address it we were wanting to get a
receiver at some point but he was just
too good to pass up right there and felt
like you know with our situation he was
the the right fit and certainly should
only help Bacchus he continues to build
on his great career yeah you knew you
were getting gold when CD lamb slid to
you this year it was four years ago when
you got that Prescott later in the draft
and nobody really knew what you got at
the time I have a feeling you didn't
know what you were getting at the time
but we all now know what that cross that
Prescott has become but that free wood I
picked him a lot earlier that's right
somebody else would have gotten before
you got a crack addict rate up into the
top five I think but Stephen as a
relates to his contract and I remember
you went through this with Dez Bryant
July 15 is that ultimate drop-dead
deadline for a multi-year deal
it's a deadline driven business is it
safe to say that that really is the
timetable we all need to be watching mid
July it gets done or it doesn't when
that when that clock strikes 12:00 or
4:00 p.m. Eastern or whatever the case
may be for closing the window on a
long-term deal for deck I think so I
mean at the end of the day I know
everybody's out there you know how have
you not paid back you know at the same
time that cast it we've tried to pay him
and he has to accept what we want to pay
him but the deals got to be right for
Doc it's got to be right for us as you
know Mike the sour cap makes this a
zero-sum game for owners this is not
something where Jerry and myself are
trying to save money so the Cowboys can
make more money for the Jones family
we're we're just trying to do our very
best working with my work and with Wilma
clay - really / the possible to win a
Super Bowl you know there's all sorts of
analytics out there that show if your
quarterback takes up too big a
percentage of your salary cap that you
know it decreases your chances to walk
and so
trying to figure out the right fit no
one wants to sign back to a longer term
deal more than Jerry and myself we're on
the record time and time again and what
we think of him as a leader he has the
it factor he's a fierce competitor he
wants to win as well and it's just got
to be right for him and right for us
we'll continue to work to a conclusion
on that I think one of the big factors
here is that franchise tag the exclusive
version of the franchise tender
thirty-one point four million
it sets up to thirty seven point six
eight million in 2021 by rule with a
twenty percent raise how big an
impediment does that option become that
ability for him to do what Kirk Cousins
did in Washington to just say I don't
want a long-term deal
I'll take thirty one for this year I'll
treat take thirty seven plus next year
and I just won't sign a long-term
contract do you think that's become a
factor in this
yeah we're not focused on we're only
focused on getting a long-term deal on
DAC we're not focused on next year the
year after that will have the resources
he's we all know quarterbacks the most
important position on this team we won't
ever be in a position where we you know
where we can't tender a franchise offer
but our strict focus is on signing back
to a long-term deal if you don't get a
deal done by July 15 how concerned are
you that he's going to exercise his
prerogative that does not show up for
anything until right before the start of
the regular season then you'll have to
have training camp and preseason I
assume with Andy Dalton like I said I
want to speak to only thing I can speak
to right now I can't speak to back only
thing I can speak to is that we're
trying to sign him to a long-term deal
he knows he's a competitor he loves his
football team and he knows that we're
trying to put a great football team
together and we're gonna focus on
getting inside a couple of league wide
questions before I let you go and I
appreciate your time here today Friday
rich McKay the chair of the competition
committee aboard that you're a member of
has said that there definitely won't be
replay review of pass interference this
year do we know or do we have an idea of
what will take its place will there be
anything to prevent another Rams Saints
NFC Championship game outcome or will it
just be
rely on the referee and the rest of the
officiating crew to get it right when
there is or isn't pass interference
there's options that we're gonna be
reviewing I don't think because of you
know this unprecedented situation where
we're not able to meet and spend the
time the competition usually does on all
the unintended consequences that come
with solutions we really build a lot of
things this year because what we don't
want to do is make a decision that does
have unintended consequences that aren't
in the best interest of the game we know
we got a great game us don't do anything
you know that had been well thought out
so there's certainly some solutions that
I think moving forward can make our game
better we'll focus on those will
hopefully get to a situation sooner than
later where we can continue business as
usual in the future where we can really
bet these and vet all the unintended
consequences that may come with these
solutions but I'm certainly on board
that we needed to move away from what we
did last year and you know these
officials do a great job they're not
gonna be perfect this games fast-moving
and but overall they do a great job we
need to support them and you know
hopefully we won't have that type of
situation again but we will look at
solutions moving forward ultimately with
replay review of past interference was
it an issue of implementation struggles
with getting it right or was it just a
concept that in your view was never
going to work because there's way too
much subjectivity within the confines of
what is and isn't interference I think
it's the latter it's just the
subjectivity that comes with what is
what is a pass interference and being
consistent with it and I think that's
the hard part is is the consistency that
every coach wants that our owners want
that our fans want everybody wants
consistency and you know these are these
guys are great athletes there's a lot of
hand fighting on every play I think our
fans like to see our players play they
don't want to see a lot of flags and I
just think it was very difficult on
judgement calls to to really get down
and have that have that be a part of
replay you've got all the Smith and
Randy Gregory under contract
currently awaiting potential
reinstatement have you heard anything
when do you expect to hear anything we
haven't heard anything I do know they
you know I think for sure Aldens men in
front of the commissioner and he's
waiting to hear back and I think Randy
Mayer I'm not exactly sure where that is
sometimes for not privy to that that
we're not sure when we'll hear something
obviously the league is looking out for
their best interests as men off the
field and certainly uh that's what's
first and first and foremost and a
priority is you know how they're coming
off the field and if ultimately they get
to a point which we think they can that
Roger feels like they can come back to
work and play football and that's in
their best interest in addition to what
they need off the field then certainly
we'll welcome them back and I go to work
when I saw that what the changes were
going to be to the substance abuse
policy with no suspensions for positive
tests moving forward etc I just assumed
that there would be some sort of amnesty
some sort of a reset something that
allows guys who were suspended under the
prior policy to come back and were you
surprised or disappointed at all that
the CBA didn't allow for these guys to
almost get a fresh start since the
policy is changing so dramatically well
it's just now getting implemented with
the new CBA so we'll see as we move
forward I know Roger his staff are
getting their hands around it I know
that certainly there's an LP a and D and
the players certainly are are looking at
how this is going to work and you know I
think at the end of the day we're going
to have something here that's in the
best interest for the players and all
the things that you're speaking of are
going to be taken into an account and as
we move forward we'll have a much better
feel for how this is gonna work all
right last one for you and this is
lawyers curse when you say last one
there usually ends up being five more
but this is the last one
and I think I know what the answer is
gonna be but I gotta ask you the
question is there any chance that the
franchise tag would be rescinded from
dak Prescott between now and the start
of the season absolutely not
that's our quarterback for the future
obviously this hadn't been the easiest
thing as Jerry says as money gets bigger
deals get harder
certainly we're talking you know a
significant amount of money here which
he so deserves but absolutely not that's
gonna be our quarterback this year he's
our quarterback for the future we think
the world of him he represents our
franchise in a very positive way in
terms of what we want as a leader of our
team and he's just an outstanding man we
would never send the franchise - well
Stephen I appreciate your time very much
I always enjoy talking to you
congratulations on the ongoing success
the Cowboys congratulations on a great
schedule all the best to Jerry and the
rest of the family we look forward to
talking again soon thank you bye
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports